(audience clapping)
Hi, Becca!
Hi!
Now, Becca, I really was emotionally struck
by why you are doing this today,
and would you please share that with everyone?
Yeah, so I mean, during my childhood,
I think myself as well as many other young girls,
went to their mom and asked, "Can I get my ears pierced?"
And at the time when I asked, I was maybe
a little too young, she was like,
"Let's revisit this in a couple years or something."
And unfortunately, before that second conversation
was able to happen, she actually passed away.
And it's been about 10 years since she did
and I've been thinking about getting my ears pierced
since then a lot lately.
And she left behind a lot of beautiful jewelry
and some of that being earrings,
and I would just love to be able now
to wear some of her stuff.
Yeah, so I think it's time, right? (laughing)
(audience clapping)
I'm so honored to be a part of this moment for you.
It's very special for me, too, yeah, thank you.
Thank you for letting me be here to witness this.
Maria, what kind of piercing do you recommend for Becca?
Well, we're gonna do her first lobes,
traditional placement first lobes
so she can wear a lot of her mom's jewelry,
which was intended for that location
and it's gonna be beautiful.
All right, let's do this.
(Becca laughing)
All right.
Woo-hoo.
Thank you for letting us do this with you.
Will you hold my hand, Drew?
Oh yeah, that's important.
Thank you!
The hand-hold is very important.
I would be honored.
So we prepped you and cleaned you before,
but I just did a quick little touch-up now for cleaning.
Okay.
And I'm gonna put a little clamp so it aligns
that front and back dot that we did backstage.
So I'm just gonna have you take a deep breath in
and just exhale.
Okay.
So take a breath in babe.
And ah, it's gonna look good, yeah.
That's the feeling.
So I'm just gonna insert the jewelry,
the hard part is totally over.
That didn't even hurt at all, that's so crazy. (laughing)
It's all in the marking and everything.
Good.
How does it feel?
I'm a new woman.
(audience laughing)
Just screwing on the star.
All right.
Now your piece is in.
Awesome.
How do you feel?
Good.
Good
Yeah, the idea of all of this really spoke to me.
Is there anything else other than earrings
that makes you think about your mom?
Weirdly tomatoes; she would like, she would slice them
at the end- like the bottom of the tomato.
Oh, we're switching, perfect.
This hand was getting sweaty.
I know we got clammy, but.
(Becca laughing)
But she would slice the avocado and then at the end
where there's like, not really any seeds or anything,
she would just like put salt on it
and we would eat it together, like the ends of the tomato.
So I think about that when I slice tomatoes sometimes.
That's so beautiful.
Was she funny? Was she serious?
Like what kind of woman?
Very funny.
She had like a really large laugh.
So yeah, and sometimes when I laugh,
my family says that they can see her, like her face;
I guess I look like her, which is good.
Really?
Yeah, so.
Okay, I'm ready again.
Okay.
Now take a breath in.
(Becca breathing deeply)
Excellent.
Number two,
Yay.
Now it's just slipping that jewelry again.
Oh my goodness.
And the hard part's over.
(Becca laughing)
Are we done?
Oh my gosh,
(Becca laughing)
It looks so pretty.
And of course I would love to show you the final product
in a mirror release,
mirror reveal I should say.
Yes, please.
Oh, perfect.
Wonderful.
Dun-dun-dun!
(Becca laughing)
Take a gander.
Wow.
(audience clapping)
They're really beautiful.
Right?
So flat to the body.
Thank you so much.
My deep pleasure,
thank you.
I mean,
this is like, what an amazing opportunity
and also thank you so much
for keeping me in such good hands.
And I'm just excited to one day be able to wear mom's stuff.
Yes, you will.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
About 8 weeks, you can change 'em.
(audience clapping)
Thank you so much you.
Thank you, Maria.
Oh, my pleasure.
Thank you, Becca.
Thank you!
And we honor your mom today.
Yes we do, she's here.
She is here.
So proud and so loving and thank you so much
for letting us be in that energy bubble of you and her.
Of course.
And honor her.
Oh my goodness, thank you so much,
this was so special and I was so looking forward to it
and it's even more meaningful than it was in my mind.
Maria, I know we've gotta end the show here,
but I was wondering what do you think?
Do you think like...
I think we should match together.
Wanna make it permanent?
Yes.
Maria, will you come up to our digital space?
I'd be honored to.
I would be your little subject and I could get a piercing?
Yeah!
(audience clapping)
Okay, fantastic.
(bright music)